do not I I own 14 weapons I've owned
weapons since I was 12 years old
I've hunted since I was 12 years old
with my father my brothers we do not
need large capacity magazines
semi-automatic weapons in the hands of
anybody in this country other than
possibly law important material what
where why do you need really old
friendly why do I need that many yeah
I've accumulated them how I say father
died and left me some my brother died
and Larrick Christmas yeah and I don't
go sell them to just anybody good I'll
buy some yes I'll buy them off I
wouldn't sell them tickets my friend
I don't know what Larry's talking about
he's totally wrong first high-capacity
magazine John John McCain made a Regis
State John McCain he withdrew it but he
made an egregious statement that said
that Barack Obama was responsible for
Orlando if anybody is directly
responsible for Orlando it's the
Republican Party force timing all manner
of gun control
Larry but lately you're not first
repealing the Second Amendment so
there's still would be 300 million guns
in America I wouldn't repeal the Second
Amendment Lieutenant General Jerry
Reagan said that Christ brought the
Second Amendment to us so you know I
wouldn't have put a repeal the Second
Amendment so there is no I wrote a book
about this there is and there is no gun
control law that has ever been proven to
reduce gun crime Australia did a
confiscation probe there is no gun
control law in the United States of
America that has ever reduced gun crime
in actually on Australia the violence we
know can we get real here first of all
if he didn't use the ar-15 there's
plenty of other guns in America maybe
they would not have been as effective
but we are not going to have the cops go
around and confiscate 300 million guns
anymore that we're gonna deport 11
million illegals this is like saying I
want more Great Lakes yeah America lives
in a total fantasy but you have to do
something you have to do something for
example like saying the people on the
no-fly list can't buy weapons no you
have to have something and I'm also for
getting rid of the ar-15s because it's
such a microcosm of what's wrong with
this everything no one will ever give an
inch you have so many thousands of guns
available do you have to have everyone K
so get you guys who it's to blame then
for the Boston bombing discerning herbs
no but what there's no guns use so if
guns are the cause of so because I
killed you with a knife instead of a gun
and someone else kill someone with the
gun guns are more difficult for people
to kill people and so fewer people will
be killed you just all that you all just
said that guns are the reason that the
terrorists are killing us nobody nobody
says islands were the reason we were
saying that gun
or a part of the problem and just admit
their advice like drugs or alcohol or
anything else and that you don't care
that some people are gonna get killed
like drugs if you say to me some people
are gonna get hurt and killed by drugs I
would say that's too bad but I still
want them just to admit it but but just
don't make it a virtue it's not a virtue
the whole point of gun ownership and the
Second Amendment is that we me I'm a gun
owner you're like you I think you are
yes because we want to defend ourselves
that's the purpose of the second member
it's not that we can go out and kill
people nobody wants anyway let me clear
something up here I don't own guns to
defend myself why do you want them I own
guns to hunt with so what happens if
someone comes in your home you're just
gonna go go
I don't own the guns in case someone
comes in my home so that I can shoot
them okay I don't intersect someone to
come in my home because I have law
enforcement and other people wrestlin
but they respond the average response
time for law enforcement is 10 minutes
so in those 10 minutes with a person
that's in your home your tongue your
knowledge 71 years old I've lived at his
country for 71 years except for the
years I was deployed fighting for this
country when I did need my gun no one's
ever entered my house and tried to kill
me
you